nach der pleite gegen bochum und dem
remis in salzburg wollen julia
nagelsmann und der fc bayern wieder
einen sieg einfahren schlusslicht
greuther fürth spielt in der allianz
arena aber frech auf gottes freistoß
fälscht sabitzer unhaltbar für ullreich
ab ein schwacher rekordmeister liegt zur
pause überraschend hinten die
halbzeitansprache von nagelsmann scheint
laut gewesen zu sein sekunden nach
wiederbeginn robert lewandowski mit dem
ausgleich die bayern jetzt zielstrebiger
und entschlossener im spiel nach vorne
der lohn das 2 2 1 1 eigentor von
sebastian griesbeck das war ihm auch
schon im hinspiel passiert führt aber
steckt nicht auf ist sogar nah dran am
ausgleich die gastgeber aber nutzen ihre
chancen jetzt eiskalt wieder lewandowski
mit seinem 28 saisontreffer in der 82
minute die entscheidung eric maxim
choupo moting setzt in der nachspielzeit
noch den vierten treffer oben drauf die
bayern holen sich dank einer
leistungssteigerung in halbzeit zwei den
pflichtsieg
[Applaus]
borussia dortmund muss zu hause also
nachlegen um den rückstand auf den
spitzenreiter nicht größer werden zu
lassen nach zuletzt zwei heimniederlagen
betreibt der bvb gegen gladbach
wiedergutmachung marco reus mit dem 1 0
nach 26 minuten und
der kapitän der schwarz-gelben geht
weiter voran super pass auf daniel malen
der überwindet yann sommer zum 2 0 für
den bvb
auch die borussia aus gladbach kommt zu
guten torchancen nach der pause
entwickelt sich die partie aber zu einem
debakel für die fohlen marius wolf in
der 70 minute drei zu null
nur vier minuten später trifft dann der
eingewechselte user mit coco und erhöht
auf 4 zu 0 beide treffer vorbereitet von
einem überragenden marco reus der dann
selber noch mal einen drauf setzt zum
ersten mal ist der kapitän an fünf
treffern in einem bundesliga spiel
beteiligt balsam für die seele aller bvb
fans den schlusspunkt setzt am rich an
per elfmeter zum 6 0 gladbach wird
gedemütigt und rutscht wieder tiefer in
den abstiegskampf
heim starke mainzer empfangen mit bayer
leverkusen die beste mannschaft der
rückrunde und die nullfünfer sind zu
beginn auch deutlich gefährlicher als
die gäste die werks-elf dagegen ist
eiskalt patrick schick mit der führung
in der 35 minute mir kt verändert die
flugbahn des balles entscheidend
leverkusens führung aus dem nichts
bringt die gastgeber allerdings nicht
aus dem konzept der sehenswerte freistoß
von aya und sorgten nach der pause für
den ausgleich für bayer ist das ein
weckruf plötzlich geht mehr nach vorne
der eingewechselte allagui nach zuspiel
von diaby in der 74 minute mit der
erneuten führung
fsv-trainer bo svensson allerdings
beweist ein glückliches händchen der
kurz zuvor eingewechselte wo es trifft
sechs minuten vor schluss erst zum
ausgleich und nur vier minuten später
sorgt im wachsen ebenfalls eingewechselt
für den vielumjubelten siegtreffer
die mainzer belohnen sich für ihre
starke mentalität leverkusen verliert
nicht nur das spiel sondern auch seinen
top-torjäger patrick schick der mit
einem muskelfaserriss in der wade
mehrere wochen ausfallen wird
personalprobleme bei der hertha kurz vor
dem spiel gegen leipzig haben die
berliner sechs positive corona fälle zu
beklagen und geraten dann nach 20
minuten auch noch in rückstand benjamin
henrichs im zweiten versuch gächter
fälscht noch ab die gastgeber stemmen
sich gegen die drohende niederlage
zunächst erfolgreich jovetic sorgt kurz
nach der pause für den verdienten
ausgleich
eine notbremse kippte die partie dann
aber marc-andré kempf fliegt nach dem
foul an den coup vom platz den strafstoß
verwandelte der gefoulte anschließend
selbst zwei zu eins für leipzig 64
minute der genickbruch für die
hauptstädter die eine stunde lang ein
gutes spiel machen wieder christopher
punkte nur drei minuten später seien
drei zehnter saisontreffer daniel mau
erhöht eine viertelstunde vor schluss
auf vier zu eins aber es kommt noch
dicker für die hausherren denn leipzig
findet weiter gefallen am toreschießen
haidach erhöht auf 5 21 berlin bricht
jetzt völlig ein
hier sucht poulsen macht dann kurz vor
schluss den deckel drauf sechs zu eins
ein neuer tiefpunkt für die hertha die
nur noch einen punkt vor dem
relegationsplatz liegt
geißbock hennes und der erste fc köln
sind hungrig auf siege und träumen
weiter vom europapokal denn in einer
über weite strecken ereignisarmen partie
gegen eintracht frankfurt erzielte joker
anthony modell ist kurz vor schluss das
tor des tages der kölner sieg letztlich
verdient weil der fc über weite strecken
die aktivere mannschaft ist und damit
voll im kampf ums internationale
geschäft bleibt
der vfb stuttgart ist die schwächste
mannschaft der rückrunde braucht im
abstiegskampf dringend erfolgserlebnisse
gegen den vfl bochum sind sie über weite
strecken die dominierende mannschaft und
gehen in der 56 minute in führung den
bochumer bella ketchup unterläuft ein
bitteres eigentor danach investieren die
gäste mehr letztlich bringt sich der vfb
aber selbst um den sieg marokkaner
stellt sich in der nachspielzeit viel zu
ungeschickt an in löwen verwandelt den
fälligen strafstoß lässig zum ausgleich
sein erster saisontreffer stuttgart ist
damit seit acht spielen sieglos
reiner maurer feiert sein debüt als
bundesliga trainer beim fc augsburg weil
chefcoach markus weinzierl in corona
isolation sitzt und er muss gleich einen
herben rückschlag verkraften bereits
nach vier minuten schließt nils petersen
einen schönen freiburger angriff
erfolgreich ab der fca zunächst
verunsichert findet aber von minute zu
minute besser in die partie und belohnt
sich dafür auch michael gregor iec mit
seinem bereits vierten treffer in der
rückrunde zum ausgleich das spiel jetzt
offen mit chancen auf beiden seiten es
sind die gäste die zielstrebiger sind
nico schlotterbeck nutzt die schlechte
abwehr von augsburgs schlussmann gibt
hier wird es eiskalt aus der sportclub
nach 26 minuten wieder vorne weil den
gastgebern in halbzeit zwei nicht viel
einfällt feiert freiburg nach drei
sieglosen auswärtsspielen wieder einen
dreier in der fremde
wolfsburg geht nach zwei siegen in folge
mit selbstvertrauen in das heimspiel
gegen 1899 hoffenheim
und auch wenn die kraichgauer in der
ersten halben stunde die besseren
chancen haben es sind die wölfe die
treffen winter neuzugang jonas wintz mit
seinem ersten treffer für den vfl nach
36 minuten äußerst sehenswert danach
verpassten es die wolfsburger die
führung trotz guter möglichkeiten
auszubauen und so kommt hoffenheim
zurück ins spiel bringen lassen mit
einem herrlichen seitfallzieher zum
inzwischen verdienten ausgleich
und nur vier minuten später dreht die
tsg das spiel sogar weil sie den druck
weiter erhöhen andré kramer rich vor dem
tor eiskalt zum 2 2 1 die mannschaft von
sebastian hoeneß bleibt damit auf kurs
champions league
arminia bielefeld muss weiter punkte
sammeln um sich luft im tabellenkeller
zu verschaffen gegen union berlin haben
die gastgeber zunächst auch ein
optisches übergewicht münzen das
allerdings erst nach dem seitenwechsel
in zählbares um rückkehrer wimmer
bedienen tokugawa mustergültig und der
japaner macht mit seinem achten
saisontor den sieg für die arminia
perfekt auch weil union bis zum schluss
schwach bleibt und auch im dritten spiel
in folge nicht trifft
der 23 spieltag im überblick bayern
dortmund und leipzig jeweils mit
deutlichen siegen bielefeld und köln
feiern wichtige heim erfolge in der
tabelle bleiben die bayern 6 punkte vor
dortmunds die plätze vier bis neun
trennen gerade mal drei punkte in der
unteren hälfte tauschen bielefeld und
die härter die plätze für stuttgart und
führt wird's langsam brenzlig
[Musik]